un aumento del gasto social en plena
campaña electoral que podría estar
viéndose reflejado en las encuestas en
la recta final del balotaje en Brasil
Que enfrentará a Jair bolsonaro y a Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el mandatario ha
aumentado sus programas de préstamos
para más de 500.000 personas en
condición de vulnerabilidad un
desembolso de 52.000 millones de dólares
entre este año y el próximo que
casualidad o no se da en paralelo a una
reducción de la distancia los sondeos
que da la victoria a la izquierda
hay 31 millones de personas muriéndose
de hambre porque hay una inflación de
alimentos muy alta
nosotros este año a través de una
propuesta de reforma constitucional
agregamos 200 reales hasta fin de año
eso significa que en este momento El
auxilio Brasil vale 600 reales y
mantendremos este valor para el próximo
año según algunos analistas esta
inversión viola las reglas electorales
al utilizar recursos públicos
desde el 4 de octubre hasta hoy tuvimos
un aumento exponencial en el número de
beneficiarios de bolsa familia y auxilio
Brasil un préstamo valorado en 600
reales que solo va hasta diciembre
Entonces esta población está tomando un
préstamo que no tendrán dinero para
pagar a fin de año y estarán condenados
al hambre estamos hablando de un
contrato con el hambre
por el momento ni la justicia ni la
candidatura de Lula se han pronunciado
ni han impugnado la decisión
probablemente para evitar las críticas
del bolsonarismo ya que la medida
beneficia aparte del potencial
electorado del ex presidente
que mejora la evaluación del gobierno el
mes pasado el gobierno sumó a medio
millón de familias a las listas de la
asistencia social adelantó pagos y
extendió los plazos del registro está
por ver si es ingrediente suficiente
para